[Musique]
pour la revue de presse bonjour julien
bonjour damien est tout d'abord on
commence avec cette candidature
historique à l'otan donc de la finlande
et de la suède on en parlait dans le
journal faut dire que la presse des deux
pays n'est pas vraiment sur la même
longueur d'onde ce matin et vous allez
le voir avec d'abord la presse
finlandaise plutôt dithyrambiques qui
titre historique en écho au discours du
président finlandais sauli niinisto pays
à la langue culture de neutralité
militaire la finlande avait noué un
partenariat avec l'otan dans les années
90 après la chute de l'urss sans jamais
y adhérer mais voilà la guerre en
ukraine a changé la donne explique le
quotidien hbl avec la crainte d'une
éventuelle invasion russe même si moscou
a officiellement toujours nier un tel
scénario en revanche du côté de la
presse suédoise changement tour radical
le svenska dagbladet évoque lui une
défaite et la fin d'un héritage
séculaire cela faisait plus d'un siècle
que la suède conserver une position
stricte de neutralité et militaires
le daghan signataire lui cible
directement la première ministre
magdalena anderson et son parti des
sociaux démocrates qui donc hier
après-midi ont donné leur aval à une
candidature à l'otan pourquoi la pilule
est amère et bien parce qu'à l'automne
dernier cette même première ministre
avait réitéré son refus d'adhérer à
l'alliance militaire elle préfère juste
site le soutien du parti à celui du
peuple écrit le quotidien cible en
incitant par dont une élue de
l'opposition pour l'accueil oubliant
aussi que les choses ont un peu changé
quand même ces derniers mois ces
candidatures communes elle marque donc
la fin d'une ère exactement damien c'est
la fin de ce qu'on appelle la
finlandisation ce concept de neutralité
militaire basée sur un accord signé à la
fin des années 40 entre la finlande et
l'urss explique le figaro et quelles
sont les conséquences est bien celle
d'avoir réveillé l'otan emmanuel
emmanuel macron pardon avait en 2019
parler de mort cérébrale de l'alliance
donald trump avait lui remis en question
le budget américain a alloué à
l'organisation et finalement avec
l'invasion russe en ukraine les membres
de l'otan semblent plus unis que jamais
de quoi faire dire à courrier
international ce dessin plutôt satirique
et surtout au vitriol on peut le dire
avec ce bladimir poutine toisé par un
gigantesque chevalier avec le bouclier
de l'otan chevalier lui disant qui m'a
réveillé avec un civil a dit martin ac
est désemparé au lendemain des
législatives au liban maintenant pas
encore résultats officiels mais déjà on
lisait une tendance un fort taux
d'abstention
et un risque d'enlisement politique et
puis on va continuer sur les dessins de
presse parfois mieux vaut un dessin de
presse qu'un long tard un long article
pour une décrire une situation complexe
à la une du canard deux hommes issus de
deux confessions différentes sont
plongés dans le noir symbole d'un pays
en déroute ou d'un côté l'électricité
est devenu une denrée rare et au
l'avenir politique reste toujours
incertain l'un des deux hommes dit à
l'autre mon leader confessionnelles vaut
mieux que le tien ou comment remettre en
question un système multi confessionnel
qui régit le liban depuis son
indépendance 18 communautés se côtoient
depuis 1920 ou 1943 selon la date que
l'on peut choisir mais n'arrive plus à
vivre ensemble pour le quotidien asharq
al awsat eh bien c'est ce système qui
mine le pays impossible de voir le liban
sortir de sa paralysie politique tant il
est impossible en raison du nombre de
confessions imaginez émerger une
majorité parlementaire à même de faire
bouger les lignes l'illustration de
cette défiance vis-à-vis du monde
politique dans le monde hier à 23 heures
nous rappelle le quotidien du soir
le taux de participation était seulement
de 41% il y a ceux qui votent pour le
clown leur communauté d'un côté et les
autres qui ne veulent plus donner foi
distille un système qu'ils estiment
auront pu malgré la contestation de 2019
et la crise économique dans lequel est
plongé le pays depuis cette date est
bien la même classe politique reste en
place explique le quotidien du soir et
je cite satisfait cette habitante de
beyrouth personne ne mérite notre
confiance
on est fatigué psychologiquement et
notre moral est au plus bas mais la
correspondante du monde qui fait le tour
des bureaux de vote dans les quartiers
chiites sunnites chrétiens c'est très
intéressant vaut prendre le pouls la
société libanaise on prend la direction
des états unis 48 heures après donc
cette tuerie de massa à buffalo dans
l'état de new york qui a causé la mort
de 10 personnes en majorité noires mois
et libération dresse le portrait de ce
tueur donc vous avez parlé dans vos
éditions tu as régis pas l'idéologie de
la suprématie de la race blanche et
haineuse à l'égard des minorités et
surtout des étrangers surtout adepte de
cette théorie du complot qu'on appelle
la théorie du grand remplacement
théorique je vais vous l'expliquer
brièvement qui prévoit un remplacement
des populations blanches occidentales
par des étrangers on en avait notamment
entendu parler pendant la présidentielle
française à l'étranger aussi cette
théorie sans fondement
inspiré plusieurs tueries aux états unis
notamment nouvelle zélande le washington
post revient sur l'origine de cette
thèse que les intérêts les intellectuels
et ex team son fondement avec cet homme
théodore bilbo élus démocrates du
mississippi dans les années 30 40 qui
avait averti à l'époque de la prochaine
disparition de la civilisation blanche
malgré les critiques donc de l'époque et
bien cette thèse depuis 70 ans a su
garder un écho d'héroïne notamment aux
prises par les élus conservateurs en
sucre c'est ce qui inquiète le new york
times comment faire face à ces idées à
ce que seul le new york times rappelle
ce terrorisme venues de l'intérieur
surtout lorsque des idées jugées
nauséabonde c'est ce qui s'échangeait à
l'époque sur des plateformes obscur et
bien sont ouvertement discutée par des
politiciens ou des journalistes
conservateur de premier rang car pour le
quotidien c'est cela qui a changé depuis
quelques années désormais des élus
républicains
que ce soit au niveau local ou national
évoque publiquement cette théorie du
grand remplacement soit par conviction
soit à des fins électoralistes mais au
final en la plaçant dans le débat public
écrit le quotidien il n'est pas
surprenant qu elle imprègne autant
certaines mentalités et en france aussi
malheureusement avant de se quitter un
point sur la politique française
justement c'est pas commun avec un
premier ministre sur le départ et tout
sourire regardez cette photo de jean
castex 682 jours sans problème
existentiel pour le premier ministre
sortant qui devrait partir
officiellement aujourd'hui écrit le
pignon autrement dit presque deux ans à
matignon son conflit politique avec
l'elysée c'est assez rare pour être
souligné jean castex va officiellement
donc remettre la démission de son
gouvernement trois semaines après la
victoire d'emmanuel macron à la
présidentielle et le parisien nous
invite dans les derniers instants du
premier ministre à matignon l'occasion
de revenir sur ces deux années passées
du côté rue de varenne pas un enfer du
tout dit il et son bilan est bien il
restera ils l'affirment il le dit il il
assure aussi comme le premier ministre
du koweït c'est comme ça voilà la trace
qu'il souhaite et ça lui va très bien
souhaite laisser aide dans le futur
merci beaucoup je suis bien chez ida